alhamdulillah
[Silence]
we are
continuing in
Z as we've mentioned
before Z is a book that is very
extensive very intense very detailed in
some parts it's incredibly detailed in
other parts it's very
general and one of these aspects in
which Z was detailed what could have
been more
detailed or we should say other books
have added to that detail are the
chapters regarding the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
appearance how he looked his physical
characteristics and also his morette
his
U different Miracles that he
performed
in throughout his life these signs these
evidences of his the validity of his
prophethood
he has a book
called
this is a book that is separate
from this is a book that he
wrote in the same vein in the same
subject regarding the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam biography and some of the
things
which are particular to
him and he mentions that one of the best
books to generally and concisely
mention most of the narrated features
physical features of the Prophet
sallam is the
book
for and so for the past few weeks in
order to augment what is
in we've referred back
to
is a book that was written from memory
during
travel he was on his way to he wanted to
spend his journey there and back with
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and so he spent his time writing
everything that he
could think up and remember of all
aspects of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam life and this is an incredible
feat because the book is a
reference but at the same time it was
written from memory and so
Parts
thatn probably wished he could have
further researched he didn't have access
to his resources and vice versa so the
book is very detailed in some places
not so much in other places very very
brief in some places
also you'll find that in it's not in
exact order that books are usually in
you'll find that he'll go through some
subjects and then he'll jump kind of
back and then he'll go forward and so
forth that's okay it was something
written for memory and it's something
that was written for students in
order for them to read and the idea is
that a person will digest and memorize
most of what's in there not that it be a
book
where a person can reference it like
a dictionary so we have referred back
to
for and we are mentioning what mentioned
with the addition of what AI
wrote after this we're going to we're at
the tail end of the chapter regarding
his physical features after that we will
get into the chapters
regarding different Miracles and the
different
phenomenon that
occurred for the prophet and was
performed for him
[Silence]
Sall
we
discussed very in in great
detail the entirety of the chapter
regarding his
physical attri rutes we also discussed
with even greater
detail the etiquette and the character
of the Prophet sallallah alai
wasam
now what's important to understand is
when we say something etiquette
character most people when they think of
the character of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
they think that he's just always walking
around smiling not making anybody upset
not sitting stepping on anyone's toes
and this is not
the
full sum of all of his character his
character was much more deep than
that but
unfortunately a lot of prophetic
character has been
reduced to
a an outward
smile and that this is a person who is
seriously reminiscent of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam character and
this is not correct he smiled often
meaning that he was a pleasant person he
was approachable it doesn't mean that he
never got got upset things never made
him upset of course things would make
him upset he's a human being he would
only he would only seek
retribution on behalf
of Allah subhanahu wa taala never for
himself he would forgive but it doesn't
mean if somebody would insult him or
attack him verbally or otherwise that he
would never get upset about this a
person human being naturally will be
offended by things how however what
makes him what makes his character
so
profound is the great amount of
willpower the incredible amount of
patience that he had with regards to
dealing with these things meaning they
would make him upset but he would
control
himself this is the Hallmark of
true
etiquette but but
unfortunately even
in even in
circles amongst the
Muslims this kind of
idea is perpetuated and it's kind of an
unspoken
thing and that is that if a person
really focuses on the prophet's
character really implements his
character he will not get by in
life live a
very shallow life we even look at it
you know a person who doesn't
lie doesn't cheat doesn't is not
treacherous does not you know these
these little traits and these kind of
passive aggressive things that if a
person doesn't do this
or if a person is not good at these
things we look at this person as a
little bit you know almost weak-minded
you
know right this is couldn't be further
from the truth people often want to
break out
of the limitations that the prophet Sall
Al
wasam explained to us with regard to the
religion of Allah there are things that
we can do that will make us get ahead in
life but they will make us get ahead in
life in this
life at the expense of our
Hereafter and so it's kind of looked at
as a person who you know doesn't lie a
little bit to get ahead doesn't cheat a
little bit doesn't backbite a little bit
doesn't spread a little chaos here and
there right some someone who doesn't
plot and plan someone who doesn't have a
little Venom in their heart that this
person is kind of simple-minded and
can't get ahead this is
something that we have to notice
recognize and we have to reject when a
person learns the Sunnah of the Prophet
Sall alai wasam and follows it they're
going to miss out on things in this D
it's going to happen you can't have
books
you can't have all of this life and all
of the Hereafter together it doesn't
work that way the scholars of Islam
refer to this life and the Hereafter
as means co-wives
right so the life of the the life of the
they're co-wives why do they say
that well the nature of co-wives is that
they're constantly competing with one
another and if you if you please one of
them it's probably going to upset the
other and vice versa and
so when a person learns the Sunnah and
Exhibits it and practices it they're
going to miss out on things in this life
but they will not miss out on the good
things of this life or the necessary
things of this life they will miss out
on all the other
things there's an
which was collected
[Silence]
by
the prophet sallai wasam tells us that
there are four traits four
characteristics if a person practices
these four disciplines these four
characteristics then don't worry about
what you miss
of the
dun you will not be harmed you will not
be affected by what you miss in the dun
now what does that mean what what do we
understand from this wording we
understand that these four traits if you
stick to them you practice them you will
miss out on things in this dun it's
going to happen but these things are not
worth your are not worth your effort
these are things that are only bad for
you in the long run so what does he
mentioned he
says that when you speak you tell the
truth a person tells the truth all the
time are they going to miss out on
things in the dun yeah they are they
going to miss out on things that's why
people lie people lie because it
advances their agendas correct
if I want to sell something and I lie
about this thing I'm going to probably
make more money on it right when a
person lies that's why people lie it's
advantageous but the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam tells us if you
discipline yourself to always tell the
truth whatever that forces you to miss
out on of this
world it is it's not worth your worry
don't fret over it it's nothing of value
he
mentions that a person is
moderate and a person only eats that
which isal only that which is lawful and
a person is moderate in his in his
eating will a person miss out yeah
they'll miss out on a five course meal
they'll miss out
on but that's not something Worthy
for a person to fret over he tells us
he tells
us that a person have good character are
you going to miss out on things with
that yes you're going to miss out on
retribution you're going to miss out on
seeing someone you dislike go through
pain all of these things that people do
to each other in order to
satisfy that which is in their hearts
that which isan encourages you're going
to miss out on these things but are
these things worth your time or worry
no and so when a person tells the truth
not because they're too simple to make
up a lie but because they are too
committed to the prophet
sallallah to make up lies when a person
has good character
and forgives people and pardons people
even people who don't deserve it
sometimes even people who don't ask for
forgiveness but they forgive them why
because they're dealing with Allah
they're not dealing with
people they're going to miss out on
certain things things are going to
happen in their heart that they have to
repress and they have to push away and
things that are going to nag at them you
want to get upset about something it
nags at you but you do not allow
yourself to
why because you see that I don't think
the prophet Sall alaihi wasallam would
have given this any of his
time this is not the way of the
simpleton this is the way of those who
are eligible for
Paradise those who Force themselves and
discipline themselves to do what's right
even if no one else is doing what's
right if
99.9% of the public and population are
liars he refuses to do it no amount of
social pressure will change that if
everyone follows this Sunnah or he is
the only one the person continues to do
it this is what is this is what true
worship of Allah subhah waala
is
[Silence]
m
it's easy to follow what your heart
tells you it's easy to feed into The
Whispers of a Shan it's very easy it's
the easiest thing in the
world because you get immediate
gratification you get immediate
gratification when you do and follow
your
impulses it takes discipline to stop
yourself from doing what's wrong even if
everyone else is doing it especially
when everyone else is doing it and this
takes us to another
point and that is
essentially why do we do the right thing
when I say the right thing what I mean
is that which pleases
Allah let's get to the heart of it what
is the reason
what is the propelling force the driving
force
behind a person repressing their anger
for instance or forgiving those who have
wronged them
or you
know overlooking things they see them
but they Overlook them right for the
betterment of themselves and
others what is the purpose why do we do
this
sometimes people are mistaken they think
that if they do these
things going to make their life much
easier and that's not necessarily the
case it's very difficult for a person to
have that baggage sometimes to Pardon
others to tell the truth to be upright
to be courageous to be truthful to be
dutiful in a place of treachery to be
good in a bad place it's
difficult and when a person is good in a
bad
place it doesn't look they're
getting
anywhere starts to feel everyone's
abusing them taking their kindness for a
weakness starts to feel you know
they're not getting
ahead because they are choosing this
path but we do not do these things
our our etiquet our
behavior is something which
Roots back to our belief in
Allah it's not because it gets us ahead
or behind in this world that's not the
reason the core reason is because we are
worshiping Allah by doing what's right
even if Allah is the only one who finds
value in that
right what does this
mean Allah subhanahu wa taala tells us
[Silence]
in
insan
Allah subhanahu
[Silence]
waala
and so Allah subhanahu waala tells us
in that one of the things he's going to
test us with to test our faith to test
the veracity of our faith is that he is
going to test
us with a lack of fruit what's that mean
a lack of
fruits a depletion in our fruits when
you look back at what the
companions explain this verse to
mean we understand the word fruit to
mean that which is physical a physical
fruit or a metaphorical fruit a physical
fruit is that you know harvests will
not yield the amount of fruit that we ex
anticipate but metaphorical
fruit when somebody
Works towards a goal and that goal is
actualized we call that a fruit right
fruit of a person's labor fruit of a
person's hard work is that their goals
are
actualized Allah subhanahu waala tells
us in the Quran that one of the things
that he tests the Believers
with is that a person will work and
fret and sweat and and in working
towards a goal and that goal not become
actualized right an example of this is
the prophets The
Messengers they would call their people
to
Islam and it would almost be they
are treading water they're getting
nowhere spent a good example 950
years 950 years almost 25
generations of of Our Generations spent
amongst his people calling them to
Islam very few people accepted Islam and
followed this is a test in a person's
fruit meaning that a person Works to F
works as hard as they can to actualize a
goal and the goal is eludes
him this is is part of our
test and so if a
person Works to follow the Sunnah of the
Prophet sallallah alaih
wasallam one of the sun of the Prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam
is one of the etiquette of the
Prophet sallam that he taught us is to
pardon people to Pardon others to
forgive give others ill Deeds their
misdeeds and their ill
will and even to pardon people and
Overlook their
their transgressions against
us this is part of the prophet
sallam
Allah only
increases those who pardon
others only increases them in stature
and
greatness and so when a person does this
they may see that the fruits of that
labor do not really yield themselves
very
well seems the harder they
try the more elusive that that becomes
this is part of our test why because we
can start to do things for the fruit
itself what are we doing it for are we
doing it in order to actualize our goals
or are we doing it in order to actualize
Allah's Allah's favor upon us this is
part of the
test and so a prophet a messenger he
will call his people with the same
enthusiasm if there's one person or if
there is a million people following him
he will have that same amount
of that same fire and
intensity these are how this is how the
prophets were and this means that in
good and in bad in times of ease and
Times of hardship in all situations the
dynamic of their of their worship of
Allah and their relationship with Allah
is not two dimensional it's very deep
it's something of
depth something that has many dimensions
to it this person is obedient to Allah
when it's for him and when it's against
him he is obedient to Allah when he
feels it and when he doesn't feel
it he is obedient to Allah when
he's when things are going good and when
things aren't going so good he is
obedient to Allah when he gets what he
wants and what he makes Dua for and when
he
doesn't this is the Hallmark of a
believer
and so this is true Ean and true Faith
the point that we're trying to make here
is
that we
cannot it it is most
crucial for a person the more
scarce the truth becomes the more
scarce the sunah of the Prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam becomes the
more critical it is for a person person
to follow the
Sunnah now it is most
critical why because who's going to keep
it alive for the Next
Generation perhaps Our Generation we we
didn't we didn't
appreciate what Allah gave us of the
Sunnah but we need to at least keep it
and preserve it so that we can pass it
to the next Generation perhaps our
children will be better than we were and
we hope that they will be better
and so the more scarce the Sunnah
becomes the more important it is that a
person adhere to it and follow it and
learn it no matter what the social
pressures the prophet
sallallah tells tells us this in the
narration
of
[Silence]
and
in a narration
in a the prophet Sall alai wasam tells
us that some
very some
very dark and wicked days lie ahead for
the people for man
kind and during these days a person
holding to the truth and holding to his
religion holding to the Sunnah of the
Prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam will
be so straining it will be trying
to hold on to LIT
coals he said for those who hold on to
my Sunnah during those days they will
have the reward of 50 men amongst you he
was saying this to the
companions the companions said 50 of us
or 50 of them he said no 50 of you to
the companions now the now this doesn't
mean that it is General reward we are
rewarded 50 times what the companions
were no what this means is that in that
particular
time where commanding the good and
forbidding the evil and holding on to
the Rope of Allah and the Sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam in
spite of its scarcity in a person's
environment that is very reminisent
inent of the beginning of Islam isn't it
that's how it was it was the prophet
sallu Al wasallam a few of his
companions nobody you know they were of
high stature and status and then when
they became Muslim all of the sudden
people started to mistreat them all of
the sudden they had to almost hide
themselves and hide their Islam they had
to pray in secret commanding the good
was unheard of these things were were
the things that we know now to be evil
at those times was considered good and
the things which we know to be good were
in those times evil right such as the
worship of Allah alone without any
Partners this is the greatest good that
a human being can do in the time when
Islam first
began first started with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in Mecca that
was something
very
strange he as Allah subhanahu Waal
mentioned that the
mus in the time of the Prophet sallallah
alai wasallam what was the main Crux the
main point of
Islam this is where the kind of the meat
and potatoes of the situation was and
that
is that those who worshiped all those
Idols in
Mecca did they believe that anyone other
than Allah created the heavens and the
Earth no did they believe that any of
these Idols or any of these so-called
Gods had anything to do with their
sustenance or their creation no they
believe that these Idols represented
good people saints that if they worship
them they'll put in a good word for them
with Allah this is the idea this is what
it
was so they all believed that only Allah
is responsible for everything good in
our
lives and so the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam told them if he is the
only one worthy of your thanks then only
thank Him worship only Allah alone
without any partners
just worship Him don't worship anyone
else this was something very strange to
them this is the greatest most pure and
this is the most basic
good that that is in humanity instilled
in the F of the human being one God one
Creator only one that I worship right
this was strange to
them and so as the
trajectory of
Islam goes throughout
time less and less people practice less
and less people adhere Islam becomes
very very strange during those
times and during those strange times a
person who has that truth and protects
it and practices it and then delivers it
to the next Generation that is of the
greatest accomplishments a person could
ever have person may follow the Sunnah
follow Islam miss out on some things in
this world but with Allah have great
stature and because of his the fruits of
his labor perhaps Generations after will
then come back to the truth and worship
Allah as he commanded because of his
tenacity and so when we learn these
things about the prophet sallu wasam we
have to practice them we have to
understand that these things are that
we're reading these are the
norm the the rule that all you know this
idea that everything that we read of the
Prophet sallallahu Al wasallam Sunnah
everything that we read in the Quran of
and it's all it it all has exceptions
all these rules have exceptions to them
they shouldn't be understood and taken
with any amount of of complete
seriousness because somewhere some
scholar has said something contrary
therefore you know many opinions and
nothing is really clear and nothing
really needs to be held to and fought
for and that couldn't be further from
the
truth to finish our small portion
here that we have at the tail end
regarding the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
regarding his physical
characteristics I didn't want to
merge the two subjects today between his
physical characteristics and his
miracles next week inshallah we'll begin
in the chapter regarding his miracles
and discuss many of them his
miracles are very numerous more than a
thousand when we try to enumerate
them but we will mention the basics and
the most well-known and others not so
welln of his physical
characteristics that the prophet
s
[Silence]
for
he tells
us a noi tells us that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam usually had
long hair as most men did at that time
often times his hair would be
braided sometimes it would not but he
would maintain it
and much of his time in Medina he
would part his hair in the middle
and then it would come down but it was
very rare to see the prophet sallallahu
alai wasallam
without his head covered without his
hair covered it's very rare most men
and most people wore things on their
head whether it's a hat or a turban or
what have you and one of the main
reasons for that is because of the Dust
the dust in the desert will get into a
person's hair and so they would usually
wrap their head sometimes even wrap
under their beard in order to keep the
dust out of their hair and out of their
beards likewise he used to comb his
beard
out likewise he would
use is a type of stone that is made into
a powder and then is placed between the
eyelids and this is something that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
commanded others
do in order to maintain healthy
eyesight it's good for the eyes it's
also good for the
eyelashes but it's a very type very
specific type of it's not just anything
it's specifically from the stone which
is known as Alid and you can
tell apart from other types of
because looks more gray than it does
black and it's almost got a
glitter in it it looks it's got a
shine to it and a glisten this is one of
the Hallmarks of real ithmid
sometimes you can buy this you know in
Islamic shops or book shops or
what have you four or five books
this is
not this is actually probably not very
good for your eyes it's jet black that's
not what real ethit looks some
of the best sources ofid are North
African countries
like
tun
[Silence]
he usually and often would wear a
th similar to this and it's something
that has two sleeves and covers the
entirety of the body and his favorite
colors were white for his clothing and
also is pin stripes something that has
pin stripes in it this is referred to as
Al and his sleeves would end at the
wrist most usually so the length of of
his sleeves would not go past the wrist
most often sometimes a little bit past
this is enough for tonight next week
we will continue and pick up where we
left
off